this is lucy james speaking for reviewer
richard wakeling beginning a review with
a history lesson is usually a bit of a
faux pas but in this case it's integral
to understanding what exactly bright
memory infinite is the original game
simply titled bright memory gained some
traction when it launched on steam early
access in 2019 for having flashy visuals
that rivaled aaa games in graphical
fidelity despite the fact that it was
the work of a single developer they
created bright memory in their spare
time and considering what a huge
undertaking that is it wasn't too
surprising when the game clocked in at
around 40 minutes in length a sequel was
due to follow but these plans were
scrapped when they opted instead to
remake the original game and expand on
both its gameplay and story that's where
bright memory infinite comes in and it's
a vastly different game from the 2019
original only tangential elements like
character and organization names remain
the rest may as well be an entirely new
project which can only be a good thing
gone are the devil may cry-esque style
ratings and blatant allusions to dark
souls instead bright memory infinite
feels less like a derivative fan game
and more like something entirely its own
a frenetic fps with satisfyingly punchy
combat that mixes both gunplay and melee
abilities into one audacious whole it's
still a fairly short experience with
some glaring caveats but the journey to
its conclusion is more enjoyable than
the original game
the reworked story revolves around a
strange phenomenon occurring in the
skies around the world that has
scientists baffled you play as shelia an
agent for the supernatural science
research organization who's sent in to
investigate it doesn't take long for
shelia to discover that this strange
phenomenon is also connected to some
mysterious history between two
interconnected worlds if this sounds
like complete nonsense it's worth noting
that the only way i know all of this is
because i looked up the game synopsis
trying to glean any of this information
from the opaque narrative is an
impossible task whether this is
intentional or due to something being
lost in translation is unclear but it's
difficult to care about anything that's
happening either way thankfully keeping
track of all this sci-fi gibberish isn't
entirely necessary the specifics of the
story will be the last thing on your
mind once you start slicing and dicing
your way through bright memory
infinite's enemies
the shotgun is a bit of a damp squib but
the rest of shelley's modest arsenal is
fun to use headshots are met with a
lofty blood spurt and a satisfying
slow-motion flourish while combining
shelly's firearms with her assortment of
other abilities is a genuine treat the
devil may cry style ratings might be
gone but you can still use shelly as
lightblade to launch enemies into the
air and then blast them out of the sky
with all the gusto of dante
the sword can also be upgraded to the
point where it flings cleaving
projectiles of its own with each swing
giving you the opportunity to utilize
the deadly blade without having to be
within touching distance
there's still a limited range so this
doesn't negate the need to use firearms
but it does make it easier to juggle
enemies once they're suspended in midair
the sword functions as a defensive tool
as well letting you deflect melee
attacks and send projectiles right back
at your foes
time it right and you can also stun
enemies and tear a big chunk out of
their armor bar leaving them open to a
devastating combo this might come from a
barrage of bullets or a rapid salvo of
sword strikes but shelia also comes
equipped with a cutting edge exo arm
this device can unleash an
electromagnetic pulse wave that turns
enemies into a pulpy mush while its
tractor beam can pull foes towards you
before you send them back in serrated
pieces there's a diminutive skill tree
that adds a few more abilities to your
repertoire like a rocket propelled punch
and a powerful ground slam so there's
room to experiment with different
combinations and dish out more damage in
one fell swoop
there's decent enemy variety too as you
switch between fighting futuristic super
soldiers and mythical beings wielding
swords spears and shields most enemy
types won't force you to alter your
strategy too much though with the
exception of armoured enemies that
dampen the potency of your attacks using
the sword's counter will break through
this armor so it's not the most
elaborate deviation but it does change
the way you have to approach some of the
adversaries you come up against attempts
at gameplay variety aren't nearly as
effective however one of bright memory
infinite's strengths is its unrelenting
pace so it's disappointing when this
comes grinding to a halt in service of a
rudimentary stealth section armed with
nothing but a blood-stained cleaver this
overly long sequence has you sneaking
through a village while trying to avoid
being spotted the instant fail state for
detection is bad enough but this section
is so stiflingly linear that it may as
well have been on rails while its
inclusion is also misguided in the grand
scheme of things
adding some gameplay variety might work
as a welcome palette cleanser in a
longer game but you can finish bright
memory infinite in an hour and 20
minutes so breaking away from its
dynamic action for a tedious digression
feels like a waste of its limited time
frame there's a brief car chase that
fares slightly better although there's
not much to it and boss battles
introduce a sense of scale to what are
otherwise close-knit fights there's just
not a lot of strategy involved in
defeating these gargantuan foes other
than dodging attacks and firing back the
grey rain-soaked environments also lack
diversity for as visually stunning as
they often are but the game's brevity
arguably works in its favor in this
instance since you're not around long
enough for them to grow stale bright
memory infinite's most egregious issues
are unfortunately of a technical variety
these faults range from subtitles and
ability descriptions still appearing in
chinese to a game-breaking bug that
completely halted my progress after
defeating the second boss roughly
halfway through the game i was booted
back to the main menu with no warning
after trying to continue my save the
game would revert back to the first
splash screen as though i was launching
it from steam again trying to choose
from the chapter select didn't work
since that was now blank and closing and
restarting the game application did
nothing so the only thing i could do was
restart the campaign over from the
beginning it's not clear if this is a
widespread issue and i did manage to
finish the game without it happening
again but it's obviously something that
can occur unless there's a day one patch
that fixes it unskippable cutscenes made
replaying the first few levels more of a
chore than it should have been and the
same remains true if you opt to replay
the whole game on a higher difficulty
level after completing it there's
nothing else to do if you want to eke
out some additional replayability and
bright memory infinite's short length is
certain to put some people off it's a
fun shooter for as long as it lasts
though offering a satisfying mix of
fast-paced gunplay and dynamic action
it's also hard not to be impressed that
this came from the talents of a lone
developer
unfortunately a dismal stealth section
unintelligible story and some technical
issues hold it back while its terseness
does make it difficult to recommend even
at a low price point
oh
yeah
[Music]